hi hey what's up I'm Jeffrey hospice and
I'm here to answer the internet would
you rather get your girlfriend pregnant
when you're 16 or get your wife pregnant
when you're 60. oh absolutely 60 because
then you don't have to watch them get
old you don't have to raise those kids
I'm gonna die my family die around 65 so
I'll get I'll get the good golden years
and then I'm hot is that it you're
thinking of cashing outside I think I
think I'll be dying around 65 to 70.
that's a dream about it too that's the
dream you don't want to linger on I
don't want to linger on but I want to
make it to 75 75 might would be fun once
I can't like Jack myself off anymore
yeah that's like why what am I doing
I'll tell you what I feel like that's
going to come sooner than later yeah
yeah truly true would you rather suck
one dick for fifty thousand dollars or
get one thousand dollars for every dick
you suck
uh a thousand dollars I if I believe in
something I do it often if I love it I
won't stop see that's why this question
feels very sophomoric but it's really
about what who what kind of who's got
that dog in there yes I'm gonna work if
you are just lazy and you want that
one-time payout or you're like I'll suck
ten thousand dicks sure sure I'll just
find like a small dick Community or
something yeah yeah would you [__] a
porn star if afterwards she had to hold
a press conference on your performance
that'd be one of the shortest press
conferences of all time all right he
went in and it was over
he said I'm sorry he was a real
gentleman about it yeah I think I'd do
fine with that if you could die and come
back as any inanimate object what would
it be I'd like to be like a a stool at
Hiroshima
you're gonna see it happen it's probably
one of there was probably a half second
where it was the most beautiful colors
of all time it was like a melange of
rainbow colors we've never seen before I
bet that wow what's going on oh I know
yeah I was jealous would you rather live
for the rest of your life with the
sensation right before you sneeze [__]
or come [__] we can all admit pooping is
the best feeling of life before so it's
like it's a that's funny but the feeling
but oh no do we get to experience the
dichotomy of the good and the bad it's
just that just the [__] feelings the
whole time you're just like I gotta [__]
again oh or but a come is like you're
about to come but you don't oh wow I
think I actually think peeing's the
worst I don't think it was nachos it
sneeze oh I don't want him these are all
terrible sneezing I get yeah I don't
know losing a sneeze is is like a day
room yeah I guess for me the sensation
right before you come as I it is brief
so yeah
and I go from one to come to coming and
pretty quick so I don't think that's
that bad I guess yeah that's not bad if
you could have one fictional dog as your
pet who would it be oh man Scooby-Doo
he's a he's a smart guy he's not a
welfare dog he doesn't make me take care
of him he walks himself I bet he's not
making me do it he's like he's like I
Don't Need No Man
I'll live that life on my own
independent dog would you rather live in
a world without headphones or a world
without doors world without doors hotels
would rock if you're just walking by
everyone [__]
that would be a fun time yeah but the
problem is it's this but headphones on
the train you have to hear what everyone
says but also we're kind of living in a
world without headphones already no one
seems to own headphones but how much
does it drive you crazy right yeah I
wanna it makes you you should get to
kill one of them a year I don't know I
was I was walking
is
our phone out loud it was just a full-on
um
feat finder it was just like like a
how-to or whatever finder it's a website
featfinder.com we're like I'm actually
like I don't know
[Laughter]
I think it was like it was a good intro
video yeah and I was like you're just
listening to this out loud right now no
shame that's why Catholicism is
important yeah it gave us guilt and
shame and that was important to us I'm
embarrassed when I like like I I
embarrassed to take a picture like not
even a selfie I'm gonna have to take a
picture or something I'm like these
[__] things up here like look at that
loser you can't remember things I won't
even answer my mom on the train I'm like
no wait wait there's strangers are wrong
that's another thing where there's
there's just two people in the world you
either do that and you don't give a [__]
yeah or you would never in a million
years if I open up my phone and like a
video plate I'm like oh I'm sorry oh my
God I'd apologize to everybody oh you
heard me playing a great Prince song I'm
so sorry I'm so sorry would you take
four million dollars to be caught on To
Catch a Predator now to be clear yeah do
I go to jail afterwards it's like it's
like a mix-up but like you like you get
proven innocent but like the air episode
and everything and it's like I saw
Jeffrey on [__] because I was like is
it worth four million dollars to be
attracted to kids my entire life I'd be
more like five million
would you take four million to be caught
absolutely that's great press that could
be my guilless moment this pedophile was
going to be on SNL
yo that really has to be one of the
worst moments of all time when you
realize you're a pedophile yeah
that really turned me on when you when
you get into eighth grade and you're
like I still like third grade
if your girl had to wear a mascot head
during sex for the rest of your life
which one would you choose wow gotta go
Buckingham you Badger I never gotta [__]
a girl in college so that'd be fun to
finally look at that dream
that'd be good finally on Wisconsin
would you rather be in a modern world
with only pregnant chicks and cats and
you can't watch porn or live in a world
where everyone is your mother and father
and you can watch
I remember these questions because
because I remember it started out with
like pregnant women and cats and he was
like but you can't even watch porn of
anything else all the porn is pregnant
women and cats too and I was like okay I
was not even thinking about that but
okay good to know also if I watch the
porn and the mother and father it's not
all just my mom and dad I thought the
porn was my mom and dad then well yes
I want to see how the sausage was made
[Laughter]
the porn's not your mother and father no
but I think it is doesn't it say that no
I think oh you can watch that okay yeah
yeah okay yeah everyone's my mom and dad
that'd be fine they're fine they don't
really like me I don't really like them
I'm finally get to be alone for once I
don't really talk that often so once a
week would you rather be able to have
sex with any five people for a year or
get to Power Bomb whoever you want
whenever you want for a year now this is
me being a virgin what's powerball mean
you put someone's head between your legs
you flip them up and then you slam them
down oh wow it's a wrestling move I
would love that because I've been such a
weak little [__] my whole life there's
a few guys from high Squad [__] love
absolutely not even a sex question I'm
30. it's overrated totally it's a pillow
feels the same coming is coming it's
over
a Power Bomb like not even I couldn't
I've never even been able to attempt
that that sounds amazing like I think it
says like like you no repercussions yeah
just boom right do it right I'd like to
know I gave some kids CTE
okay if you were taking hostage five
years ago what would surprise you most
about the world today wow okay I would
be surprised at how ugly gay people are
we were told our entire lives they're
all glistening adonises and now that
they're all coming out they're not all
hot there's some real swamp creatures
just emerging and I think that's good
yeah I was just normal I would have
thought everyone you had to be hot to be
gay I was like I guess I can't be gay
now I'm like I guess I can be gay I'd be
in the middle of the pack no yeah that's
a phenomenal answer what is the fiercest
animal you think you could take in a
fight oh man I don't I they got an
ostrich on here I could probably take uh
coyote I think I could take a coyote I
think if I think I could take we don't
do I get implements or tools or bare
hands I think I could wrap it around I
think of a coyote walked in here you
would be so [__] now that you say that
I think I would probably but you know
life or death if I I think I could
scrounge up a little human Ingenuity and
find a rocker stick on the ground I
think coyote would like Mall me but like
to the to the death I don't think they
have the instinct to live like I do
right so they'd like bite me and they're
like that was pretty also I probably
don't taste good so you're playing
you're just getting to the Bone
immediately they're not yeah I think I
would win oh okay if you could put any
franchise restaurant in your house what
would it be you gotta go Perkins is that
do they have it on the East Coast
Perkins in the midwest I love the vibe
of a Perkins I love so does Tiger Woods
he just did that where he went to like
the waitress yeah wow good for him a
good guy I love Perkins and Denny's one
of those because you get to see old
people it's the last place old people
can be like kings before you die and you
[__] your pants you get a Perkins and
you get treated like a [__] king for
a morning I love Perkins are there any
universally loved movies that you hate
oh wow Ghostbusters I think it sucks I
think those 80s comedies are complete
trash they're not funny anymore they
have like a joke every 17 minutes
they're just like it's just like kids
like Ghostbusters rocked it's like no
your parents were still together
it wasn't good you just thought you
would become a doctor still and now you
work in Insurance like that's what it
was
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out